how is it possible something that giant
comes out there it just looks like
something out of a sci-fi horror movie
that's not helpful
Sam is the love of my life happy
engagement have some difficult news the
blood test shows that you are not
pregnant
oh there's this moment when everything
changes you have a mass that is cancer
this is the moment at least we won't
have to pay for college this is a really
smart to her welcome to the last group
you ever wanted to be my brother
I was it still holding up I hope she
keeps up the bird-watching
banging's
welcome to group grab a sit right there
I feel underdressed alright guy Coke's
does it it's not dead yet so it's got to
be doing something like I'm just trying
to find something positive here your
week is pretty it's my hair this is a
disaster who's gonna match your socks I
can take care of myself but what if you
can't fix things just though let's be
real
Sam's gonna be a chick magnet he's never
had to date which I'm freaking pretty I
decided to cut out gluten okay if you do
get better they're gonna feel like a
real ass you are not allowed to talk to
me like that I'm sick no you no no come
on that's not gonna work
she's gotta be scared out of her mind
right now Susan's to know that you were
gonna be okay
setting me up are you serious you don't
have as much time as you think you do
it's true for you it's true for every
person on the planet all the what-ifs
I'm missing out on what is I thought if
I planned your whole future
it wouldn't hurt so much not to be a
part of it
[Music]
so the things we do for the people along
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
you